following reports of poor attendances on
previous day's was a very different
fields of the Khalifah stadium on Monday
thanks mainly to the African fans they
certainly had lots to cheer about with
African athletes winning half of the
gold medals on offer the women's 800
meter final produced one of the night's
most dramatic finishes Ugandan halima in
the cave upsetting pre-race favorite aji
Wilson to win gold for the reigning
Olympic champion caster Semenya is still
fighting the iwf in the course over
their testosterone rules the podium
could have a very different look to it
on the Tokyo Olympics next year
kirsta I thought she was our good friend
we still respect her however my summer
it created more opportunity for others
but I'm real proud of worries and they
respect her another great finish and
another African success in the men's
5000 meters has looked our address
defended his title as he led an
Ethiopian 1/2 out of Salomon Vega
[Applause]
two years ago in London Kenya's Beatrice
chap coetc slickly took a wrong turn in
a 3,000 meter steeplechase that mistake
cost her a world title then she made
amends in Doha on Monday to win her
country's second gold of these
championships one of the night's most
eagerly awaited finals was the men's
400-meter hurdles with three of the
fastest men in history all taking part
defending champion Caston wore home
retaining his title ahead of America Ray
Benjamin and cut out AB dorama Samba
Samba winning his country's first medal
of Doha at 2019 but celebration of the
day undoubtedly came from Daniels style
the Swede winning the discus and then
making a late bid for the Swedish track
team aljazeera
[Applause]